programming languages come and go but
python
is different it's one of the few
languages that consistently gains
traction
and as the community grows so does the
power of the language
and now you can be part of the python
community
python is one of the simplest coding
languages to learn
it's used for everything from sending
reminder texts to classifying images
that detect
diseases that diversity is why python
powers some of the best-loved
apps in existence including instagram
netflix and spotify
if you've dreamed of unlocking python's
unlimited potential
udacity's brand new intermediate python
nanodegree program is for you
it's designed and taught entirely by
industry insiders who work in the field
it's perfect for those who have used
python to build basic scripts
but want to up their game you'll learn a
language that's frequently used in full
stack web development as well as for
powering artificial intelligence and
data science
and you'll be learning by building real
world projects
including a motivational quote meme
generator
these projects showcase your skills to
impress potential employers
the new intermediate python nanodegree
program from udacity
taught by the best so you can build the
applications that will power the future
bye